sixteen years after 9/11 the US
continues to fight radical Islamic
terrorists in Afghanistan the conflict
there has been America's longest war on
record thousands of Americans have been
killed nearly 2,500 and it has caused
over 1 trillion dollars 60-minutes this
Sunday will air a full report on the
current situation and they gave us an
exclusive preview now watch this clip of
60 minutes correspondent Lara Logan
describing what it is like for the US
military in Afghanistan's capital of
Kabul a few years ago American convoys
regularly drove on the airport road
below now the view from the helicopter
window is almost on board we'll see of
Kabul they'll stay behind glass walls
for the rest of their time in
Afghanistan we wanted to know what it
says about where we are in this war if
American troops can't drive two miles
down a road in Kabul it's a country at
war and it's a capital that is under
attack by a determined enemy no US
General has spent more time here than
John Nicholson the commander of American
forces in Afghanistan we do everything
possible to protect our forces so
protecting is in the road protecting the
lives of our troops is a no more part if
we if we can fly instead of drive and
that offers them a greater degree of
safety then it's the prudent and the
right thing to do in military terms
that's called surrendering the terrain I
disagree I think it's it's answering our
moral imperative to protect the lives of
our soldiers and civilians so that's
what we do 60 minutes correspondent Lara
Logan is whether it's not so good to see
you thank you you're you're like Sarah
Carter you spent 20 years in more than
two decades in war zones
you were CBS's chief foreign
correspondent in 2006 chief foreign
affairs correspondent 2008
you're still going back to these war
zones why is this such a passion Igor's
why is it such a passion because I
believe in it I believe that it's
important that we go out on the end of
the line to the places that some people
might not want to go we'll be able to go
and we hold our leaders and our selves
accountable for the decisions that we
make and but you do put yourself at risk
when you do this you know I remember how
awful we watched what happened into here
square and I remember what you said at
the time when you spoke about he said in
a moment everything went wrong and I
know it broke my heart and a lot of
people's hearts about what was happening
to you but that's the environment you're
still throwing yourself back into those
environments
what should you stuff you don't do it
for the adrenaline right if it costs you
that much you have to do it because it's
that important to you and it's sort of
like you right I feel this is the reason
I was I was put on this earth you know I
want to be the best mother I can be
that's so important to me but this is
like breathing for me it's it's why I
was born that's that's an amazing
commitment to what you think your life's
purpose is so was 16 years later in this
interview that will air on 60 minutes on
Sunday you do talk to the US commander
in Afghanistan you also talk to the
Afghan president what are they telling
you 16 years later well you know general
Nicholson has a tough job so does
President Ghani and I say that with the
utmost respect for what both of them are
dealing with and it's our job to be
tough and and I was really tough and two
there well especially general Nicholson
you know to his credit he didn't dodge a
single question and he's been there
longer than any other US general and he
has served a number of times and he's
very very committed to this but his you
know to some degree he's facing an
overwhelming challenge so we wouldn't
like that though he he thinks he can win
well he actually in the interview with
you he actually says that it's more
important than ever that we win that we
beat Islamic militant terror we need to
defeat the ideology and he said if we
lose here or if we were to leave here
the cost would be unacceptable explain
what he was actually saying there cuz
the president gave him three thousand
more troops I said to him you know
Americans
more concerned about a guy going to rent
a truck from Home Depot than they are
about terrorists coming from Afghanistan
to attack and he said that's exactly the
point is if you if you lose here you
embolden the guys who are going to Home
Depot and in his view that's what makes
it so important to defeat the ideology
because the ideology is what drives
every attack on any part of the planet
and what's the one thing shown that has
never changed and that every single one
of them share doesn't matter if it's
Timbuktu or Paris or New York they share
the exact same ideology and that's why
it just bothered me so much I won't drag
into politics when the president
overseas contingency operations man
cause disasters the mysterious
reluctance and resistance to say radical
Islamic terrorism like the commander is
telling you we have made tremendous
progress I want to get your perspective
having been over there so many times did
the rules of engagement now being
changed to let the commanders on the
ground and the troops on the ground make
the decision is that responsible for the
last year the degrading of Isis that we
have seen so dramatically are you
talking now about Afghanistan or beyond
talking Iraq
generally speaking who is that Bhosle
pushed out of Iraq but we still have
which we're dealing with terrorism
obviously it's a worldwide problem well
the Iraqi said just this week that there
at least 3,000 Isis terrorists still
operating in their kind of war or less
far less yes so the any military
commander will tell you that easing the
rules of engagement than having the
latitude to make decisions on the ground
is is hugely significant there's always
more factors involved but my experience
I pay a lot of attention to what these
people say and to what they do and they
they very often tell you they Telegraph
for you their intentions and they see
this as proof the fact that they were
forced out of rock and they were forced
out of mobile Mosel reinforces their
propaganda and their message because
it's proof that the u.s. that the rest
of the world isn't going to let them
have the caliphate that they deserve the
courage of people like you and
and Sarah Carter and after all you went
through to keep going back to these war
zones it's it's important we're glad you
do it we'll be watching Sunday nights
on 60 minutes Thank You Laura for
stopping by